[Musique]
si vous avez essayé de prendre
rendez-vous chez votre médecin
aujourd'hui vous avez peut-être eu
encore plus de mal que d'habitude la
majorité des cabinets étaient fermées
pour cause de grève les généralistes
mais aussi les soignants hospitaliers
dénoncent une nouvelle fois le manque de
considération pour leur secteur environ
15000 médecins ce sont mobilisés en
France depuis le 9 février la région
Île-de-France subit un épisode important
de pollution de l'air les basses
températures et les vents faibles ne
favorisent pas la bonne dispersion des
particules de CO2 dans notre département
c'est principalement le Nord et l'Est
des Yvelines qui sont impactés la
situation devrait revenir à la normale
dans les prochains jours il n'était pas
présent pour accueillir le ministre des
Transports Clement Beaune la Présidente
de la Région
Île-de-France la mer de Paris et les
présidents des départements des Yvelines
et des Hauts-de-Seine ont tous boycoté
la visite du ministre concernant le
chantier du RER Eole il dénonce le
manque de financement de la part du
gouvernement
nous n'avons à ce jour pas le premier
euro pour faire fonctionner les trains
qui relieront en 2024 Saint-Lazare et la
défense le bus santé femme revient les
16 et 17 février à plaisir le jeudi il
sera sur l'esplanade du centre
commercial du valibout et le vendredi
sur le parking du centre commercial
Brigitte l'objectif rompre l'isolement
des femmes et leur donner accès à des
conseils santé et juridiques et
aujourd'hui nous sommes le 14 février
c'est le jour de la Saint Valentin vous
avez peut-être déjà acheté des fleurs ou
un cadeau pour votre partenaire en
France certains commerçants triple leur
chiffre d'affaires beaucoup d'hommes
beaucoup d'amoureux tout va bien c'est
une fête qui marche bien et avec ces
tâches ça va vraiment des plus jeunes
tout le monde tout le monde fait le 14
février c'est quand même un jour qui est
très intéressant pour nous caviste ce
jour-là qu'on propose plusieurs types de
produits notamment les champagnes
champagne rosé qui passe très très bien
mais alors pourquoi fait-on l'amour ce
jour-là il s'agirait en fait d'une fête
païenne célébrée par les Romains durant
le mois de février ces derniers célébrés
les dieux de la fécondité et du mariage
de 1000 ans plus tard c'est resté la
fête des amoureux
[Musique]